so today we're going to talk about
measurement and fairness and we will
talk about what that even means
but it's mostly about a bunch of
questions that we could ask ourselves
when we are working on an um automated
decision-making process it's usually
machine learning but it could it doesn't
have to be machine learning
a little bit about me i got my phd in
interpretable methods for cancer
diagnostics and then i attend being a
machine learning consultant and then
that was when
i turned into doing open source i got
involved with scikit-learn
and then i got involved with fairlane
and then i worked in an algorithmic
privacy fairness team and now
these days i work at hugging face as a
machine learning engineer
some ground rules
for for such a talk to work well and for
you to get the most out of it it has to
be a safe space
no judgment
if you have questions if you have doubts
it is okay to ask them it's okay to
share those experiences
if you are already here in this talk it
means that you are curious you want to
know more um it's okay if you ask the
wrong questions there's there's no such
thing as a wrong question
um
and
ideally when we go out we don't judge
others for the questions
it would be nice if we could keep the
session a little bit interactive so now
before we start what i want you to do
um is to think of a system that is
relevant to your work maybe or you're
curious about or you're studying
and try to be very specific for example
it could be a recommendation system or a
text edge or image search or voice
recognition anything and as we go
through the exercise it would be nice
for you to go through the exercises for
your own
use case
and also if you have questions related
to the exercises we go through ask them
as we go so now i'm going to give you a
few seconds to think about what you want
to think about during the session
right hopefully you have something by
now
um now we're going to talk about
fairness it's very important to realize
that it's a socio-technical issue
it is not an issue that we can solve by
just doing math
and in most cases when you start
thinking about these issues the problems
can be solved not necessarily by
changing your model or algorithm it
might be able you might be able to solve
it or improve things by doing something
in your
data collection stage or what people do
with the output of your
your system
and it's really important to think about
who are the affected people uh we go
into more details shortly
first we're going to talk about
different types of harms and some of the
relevant types of harms that when you
work in machine learning or like
automated decision making processes
they're kind of relevant
they are we're going to talk about
allocation quality of service
stereotyping denigration
and over or under representation
allocation it means that if your system
is used to allocate certain resources
to people
then you might be harming a certain
group if you're systematically not
allocating that resource to that group
an example is when um amazon was going
to deploy an ai-based system to scrap
through
the
applications and choose the ones that go
forward and then people realize that the
system is being very sexist so they
dropped that and they never ended up
using it
or quality of service if you are
like this example is you take the image
and then you
detect the gender first of all
the first question is why do you need to
detect somebody's gender from their
image if you want to know somebody's
gender you probably should ask
and you probably should
think twice if you really need some to
know somebody's gender but if you are
like for some reason in it in a system
where you want to do that um then
researchers compared a few existing
systems um a few years ago
and they could see that the system works
a lot better for people with lighter
skin colors than darker ones and it
works a lot better for
men than it does for women it means that
if you are using deploying this as a
part of another system that uses this as
a feature then you are being very
inaccurate for a certain group of people
stereotyping
[Music]
this example is latanya sweeney who's a
professor said her own name on google
and the ads that she got we're all
related to checking whether this person
has any criminal history or not or has
like um has she been arrested or not and
that's basically because she has a black
sounding name if you look for a white
sounding name it wouldn't you wouldn't
get the same um
ads
and you're like this this person
obviously hasn't been arrested um so
if somebody searches for their name
instead of like up there being old like
other things related to conferences and
her research they're going to see such
advertising
the next one is denigration
another
high profile case was when this
image tagging algorithm tagged
a picture of black people as gorillas
you obviously don't want to do that but
these are the things that you need to
think about and and you need to test for
and the next one is representation
you would look for ceo on a search
engine and you wouldn't get um
any women up there and the first one in
this example would be a barbie doll
who's a woman like you don't the first
woman that you get is not even a human
um it's like obviously these are the
cases that people have talked about and
search engines have improved so if you
if you search now you get much better
results but these are the things that
people didn't really think about back
then
and it's also important to know that
different types of harms related to
to a system that you deploy is not a
single one you might have one single
system that is inducing multiple types
four different groups
so who are the affected people how do we
think about that um it's not just your
end users uh you also need to think
about direct or indirect stakeholders
that you have for example you might
deploy a system that affects a certain
group of people but that group has a
profession that because of your system
might change their behavior and that
change in behavior is
impacting their customers for example if
they're doctors they're impacting their
patients if they're teachers you're
impacting their students
um you depending on where you are
you might think about who are your
legally protected groups
um and then you go a step further and
you think about historically
marginalized groups of people
again these are this is not a universal
thing depending on where you are like
the answer changes
and it's also not really easy always to
identify most relevant groups and an
example is think left-handed people
the first release of iphone and youtube
does anybody know what happened then
no guesses
back then youtube realized that about 10
percent of uploaded videos are upside
down
that's because all the engineers who
tested the algorith that the platform
were right-handed and they just ignored
the metadata in the video that which
direction
the video is
um it does show how also diversity in
your team really matters and it's not
just about gender or race diversity like
any kind of diversity it really helps
your product
um and obviously the most relevant
groups can be very specific to your use
case not just your company the use case
if you're a large company
you don't want to have one team doing
your fairness related consent and then
dictate that to the rest of the rest of
the company you really need to go and
check for every single use case
so
um
to recap we talked about groups of
people that might be affected and types
of harms i want you to spend a few
seconds and think about the use case
that you had in mind and what kinds of
harms it might impact and for for whom
and if you have questions or feedback
just shout
yes
um so for allocation bias
um is that always the type of like for
example in local government we might
have a scheme that is
is that actually
if i understand the question correctly
you're asking if allocation is
always a type of harm or if there is
sometimes there might be a disparity but
doesn't harm people and is that the
question
so the um when you think about it the
cases that get to the news or the cases
that end up in the court um it's usually
because a certain group is
being harmed or discriminated against in
a systematic way
um that's why we focus on the harm and
not just blindly checking for
disparities between different groups it
matters whether what you're doing harms
somebody or not or a group or not if not
then you you are probably okay
fallen yes hard times you want to help
them
if a small proportion of those people
feel denigrated by being offered
discounts on cheap stuff
would that be a harm that would prevent
you from running the program
um so the question is if you are having
a system which offers discounts to
customers and some people might be
offended if they get discounts on cheap
stuff
so you mentioned that
you are targeting them because you think
they have some financial trouble
um the question is um is that what they
perceive
um the um there is a big difference
between your your intents and and the
perception um
and if they don't necessarily perceive
that if if the kind of service that you
they get so this is a great example
because you um which means that you have
a system which probably detects whether
somebody or whether your customer has
financial troubles or not and then you
have another system which is going to
offer them discounts based on the output
of that model
just doing that is okay but then the
question is is that same model going to
be used in a different system in your
platform and maybe not offering those
same people alone maybe because you know
that um
based on this system they they have
financial trouble but you're not going
to give them a zero percent um loan on
the product that they could buy so just
giving them discount is not hurting
anybody it may it it might be a resource
that you're not allocating to another
group that um so
it doesn't hurt people who do get the
discount it hurts people who don't
but it might hurt because
because of the way you made that
decision it might hurt
these people who do get the discount
because you
uh prevent them from getting other
services on your platform
and then that would be problematic
so
now we get to measurement modeling it's
um it's a framework borrowed from social
sciences specifically quantitative
social sciences where we deal a lot with
concepts
in that context they're called
constructs
which are not necessarily measurable in
an easy way think intelligence or
political ideology but we want to study
these concepts therefore we want to
measure something we want to have proxy
variables that kind of represent those
concepts
and do stuff with them
in that
language we would say a measurement
model is a statistical model that links
unobservable theoretical constructs
operationalized as latin variables and
observable properties as in for example
i want to
know somebody's socioeconomic status i
take their income as a proxy variable
or i want to know
what kind of outfits they care about
then i probably take their gender into
account
it's like it matters why you are using a
variable in in your decision making
processes
um and it's a lot about the fact that we
make assumptions in the process uh from
the very beginning when we start
collecting data to how we use the
outputs
of our systems
and we would like to make those
assumptions very explicit and then test
those assumptions
so we start with a very easy example
measuring height what can go wrong when
we measure height
someone's wearing shoes
very good
social desirability
511 yes and yes
um so the
um shu is like definitely one example do
we count that in height or not hair is
another one do we count that or not and
then um it's not the answer is not very
clear are we talking in the context of
like a medical setting where the actual
body height matters or is it a social
setting where the perceived height is
more important than the actual height if
i wear platform shoes with like five
centimeters heels like all the time then
i'm a taller person like in all the
social settings that i got
also like how do i collect this um am i
taking pictures and guessing the height
or am i using a ruler or do i scrap the
data from a
dating platform where people do lie and
then there was a study that showed that
the bias is also not
uniform as in men exaggerate more often
and when they exaggerate they exaggerate
more than women so you have bias data
but it's also biased not uniformly for
all for for everybody
now we talk very shortly
about a few use cases that we're going
to refer to later in the talk
socioeconomic status
people usually take income as a proxy um
and it can be just the value of the
income or a
non-linear or um some stochastic
relationship to the income
um but then there are questions how are
we measuring income is it before tax
after tax do we take insurance
deductions does it matter what kind of
insurance they have that they are
deducted from the income
how did that how does that affect this
socioeconomic status another one is
measuring teacher effect effectiveness
which is a system in the us
where you have a system supposed to tell
you how good a teacher is how much added
value does this teacher bring to the
students
and what they do is that they take
students scores
across years or only that year depending
on how standardized are
and then they measure some score for the
teacher
compass probably the most well-known in
the in the fairness literature
it it is a system that is supposed to
tell you what is the chances what are
the chances of this person being
re-arrested for a misdemeanor or felony
in the in the next two years
another one is measuring patient benefit
um as in
do i want to refer this patient to
another program and enroll them early so
that if they have a complex health issue
um they get treated earlier and it helps
them and it helps the health care system
with like lower costs
but some lesser stuff uh imagine a wine
recommendation system i just want to
recommend wine based on the food that
people are eating um does could that
have issues
and another one content moderation
system think about having maybe a
platform a retail or some content
platform where people leave comments or
reviews and you want to flag and exclude
things that are quote unquote
inappropriate
so
how do we test these assumptions um we
and why is that important
again um from from that article
leaving these assumptions implicit or
untested obscures any possible
mismatches between the theoretical
understanding of the construct what you
wanted to measure
performed to be measured
and its operationalization the the latin
variable the proxy variable that you're
actually measuring
in turn obscuring any resulting fairness
related harms
the first one is construct reliability
which
is test retest reliability it is very
much related to the concept of
statistical
precision to the inverse of variance
meaning that if i have if i'm measuring
something if i go and re-measure that
thing do i get the same result
for example in the um teacher assessment
tool um there was a case where a teacher
in new york city with 26 years of
experience the first year
he got a score 6 out of 100 and the next
year 96 out of 100. it's very improbable
that this person changed their value
added to the students
in one year after after so many years of
experience
so the the value that i'm the measuring
is the effect effectiveness of the
teacher but it has such a high variance
and i can't really explain it so maybe i
need to go back and like double check my
system
another one socio-economic status
i measure maybe i'm a bank and i have
access to people's
data
do i have a high variance for some
individuals across months it's very
improbable that they change
their socioeconomic status from months
to months maybe the reason that i see
that high variance is that they get
sometimes their income at the end of the
month sometimes at the beginning of the
month and i was just doing a group
buying in python and like
getting whatever it is in a month
and like these are the things that it's
none of these questions are
really like wow such a such a smart
question it's more like there are a set
of questions that if you actually
bothered to go through the exercise you
detect a lot of issues that
would go unseen
another one content moderation system
i'm flagging
comments
do i flag them
always the same way do like if i have
two similar comments do they get flagged
the same way or even like if i give this
to multiple people do they like flag it
the same way
um
and if not
then maybe i need to have better
guidelines and train my annotators in a
better way so that i get a more
consistent result
and the next category are about
construct validity
we here we like we deal with questions
such as
do these measurements look plausible
are we
measuring everything related to this
concept that we wanted to measure
or are there any
uh what are the consequences of um
measuring these or deploying these
measurements
and it's a feature not a bug that the
answers to these questions are not yes
no it's a very gray zone it's a spectrum
and
at the end of the day you need to kind
of measure how much risk you have how
much how much in the right area you are
or how much in the wrong area you are
the first one is face validity you can
think of it as kind of a sniff test you
just look at the data does it look okay
for example do you have anomalies
should you ignore them
if it doesn't look okay maybe you
imputed the data in a weird way or the
imputation went wrong
or maybe you have a very unexpectedly
high variance that you cannot explain
so this one you can measure in a
quantitative quantitative way
and when we think about for example
height measurement i could go and check
if the values that i have in my data set
kind of agree with the data that i have
from the scientific reports for the
demographics that i have here
or um if i i'm dealing with
socioeconomic status
if the values don't look realistic maybe
i had the issue that in some countries
they separated decimals with commas in
some countries they separate them with
dot
another one is content validity
and it's about whether we completely
understand and measure the concept we
want to measure or not and whether we
are only measuring the thing that we
wanted to measure it has three sub
aspects contestedness some substantive
validity and structural validity
the first one contestedness it means if
i ask basically if i ask multiple people
what does this concept mean to you do
they more or less give me the same
answer
and if they don't it means that probably
a single number cannot represent that
concept
and whatever you're measuring you're
measuring probably only one perspective
and it's not necessarily an issue that
you're measuring one one perspective you
need to document it this is an
assumption that you're making you're
you're making the assumption that this
is what i want to measure
and you document that and everybody
downstream
who's going to use this data or the
output of the model knows that this is
what you're talking about
for example think customer value
what can we think about in terms of
customer value and contestedness
how much they spend or how often they
come
they're two different aspects yes
when it comes to customer value do we
care about short-term value
do we care really about whether or not
they're going to buy something right now
or do we care about this customer
staying there and like buying something
in a few months
do i care about what they spend on the
platform or do i care about their
loyalty and how much they referred
others to the platform and how good or
bad they talk about my platform when
they talk to their friends and these are
very different things and they they need
to be used differently based on what you
really want to do if you have a system
that one team measures customer value
and all other teams are using that value
it needs to be very explicit that what
kind of value that team was measuring
and whether or not that applies to your
use case downstream
another one is like when you're dealing
with inappropriate comments in the
content moderation case
um why are we flagging something is it
because it was racist sexist homophobic
etc or is it because it's adult content
and i don't want maybe to have adult
content on my platform
or does it violate a certain law
which law or maybe i just don't want to
have these comments on my platform
and making again these explicit and have
the annotators writing down which reason
they chose to flag this would help your
modeling to also have different classes
while you're flagging them you can also
then give the feedback to the customer
why they're
comments are being blocked or hidden and
then they can correct that
another one is
substantive validity as in
do i encampulate everything that is
related to what i need to encapsulate
for example
again socio-economic status and income
maybe income is not the only thing that
i care about wealth is another one
education is another one
by looking at the income i don't
necessarily get their their status
but which one is really the one that is
relevant to me or in case of like one
recommendation
did i only take into account
the food or should i care about the user
budget or use their preferences maybe
it's a it's a person who really likes
red wine with fish like who am i to
judge
or
the regional variations
on on food and wine um
[Music]
i can't recommend something i don't know
like if you go from country to country
especially in europe the preferences
change massively if i have one universal
system it's not going to work for
everybody another one is um structural
validity and this is more like if i do
have assumptions mathematical
assumptions or relationship between my
variables
do they make sense for example if i have
a causal diagram do i have all the edges
that are relevant or the are the
direction of the edges correct
or if i have a
mathematical model for example in the
case of the teacher performance there is
a like the the dot
the paper documents how it's calculated
does that make sense
or if i use a linear or non-linear
relationship to income for socioeconomic
status is that a valid assumption
so
in this part we talked about construct
reliability test retest reliability and
construct validity first one was the
face validity which was kind of a sniff
test
and then content validity
some of these we can assess in a
qualitative way some of them
quantitative and we need to think about
them both in terms of our inputs and
output of the model
the next one is conversion validity i'm
going a bit faster because i'm out of
time almost
[Music]
this means that if i have multiple ways
of measuring the same thing do they
agree or not
for example in the case of teacher
performance
[Music]
would i get the same kind of score if i
took into account
the peers and principles reviews of the
teachers
it also raises the question if i do have
multiple ways of measuring the same
thing do i need a new way of doing that
same thing it might be like saving costs
but is it worth it
and then even if i do have two different
ways of
measuring something and they both agree
maybe both of them are wrong for example
in case of predictive policing
i am sending cops to a certain area and
then they are arresting people
i'm it looks like i'm
predicting the right thing because they
go there and they arrest people ignoring
the fact that well people cops arrest
people where they are if they don't go
to a neighborhood they're not going to
be arresting people
another one is discriminant validity as
in
things that should be correlated are
they correlated
and the other way around or not
for example if i look at my
socioeconomic status and if i have data
on gender and race i probably should see
some correlations because of the social
structures that we have do i see those
correlations or not
and then do i want to fix for that
another one is if i'm
measuring the the patient's future care
costs
does that correlate with
with race or not and then a study showed
that um it it was the opposite as in i
was referring more white people than
black black communities and but that my
black community was more sick
i'm going to skip these two
and then
we get to consequential validity this is
where most of the fairness related
issues are raised
as in
what are the consequences of deploying
this um this model and we deal with
questions such as um
how is the world shaped based on my
measurement
and is that the kind of world that i
want to live in and then if there are
conflicts do i want to change that
you can go through these questions um
regularly in your system
who are impacted by by my system
how does the system change the world
what are the consequences desired by the
system what are the positive ones that i
want to focus on and what are the
negative ones that i want to mitigate
and
for example in the um
content moderation system i might um
like if i if it's in english and then
people of color and black communities
kind of speak in a different way and
write in a different way am i flagging
their comments with the same rate with
the same accuracy that i'm flagging them
with people
who write the way that maybe white
people in the us
speak
kind of more or less
or if i'm dealing with a language that
is across a bunch of countries like i'm
dealing with german and then i have
maybe most of my data comes from germany
but then switzerland speaks like in a
different way a little bit and then you
have austria that speaks in a different
way if i have one language model does it
work for those countries or not
so now the best part is thinking about
fairness as a construct
when i think when i talk about fairness
income like in in the machine learning
space we probably are going to measure
that as its single value or a few values
and i want to optimize for that somebody
says make that better or i want to make
that better
does that even make sense
if you think about fairness as a
construct
so the comment is like isn't venice
biased itself something that is fair for
somebody it's another thing for another
person yes so it is kind of contested as
in like what what even
means means different thing to different
people
um
somewhat based on their ideology
um and we can like fight all day long
like which one is correct but it's like
it's it's just a contested context it's
also test retest reliability like you
ask different people what was fair as
you said no they're like most people
don't agree
what that means is that it makes sense
now that we have very different
definitions of fairness
um
there is like you can think of in one
aspect like way of thinking it is like
you have group fairness and you have
individual fairness there is also
counterfactual fairness that we don't
talk about individual fairness focuses
on
similar people should be treated
similarly but then the question is what
does it mean that people are similar
what do i take into account
and even if i'm taking everything into
account do i take into account what they
are now or do i take into account their
past or do i take into account this
individual's past or do i take into
account this group the group that this
individual is belonging to
and they're like that whole historical
context
and then group fairness
we have many different definitions and a
lot of them conflict with one another if
you optimize for one and you lose on the
other one
and
the example is compass that it got into
news because incorrectly uh it would
incorrectly score black uh defendants as
high risk more often than white
defendants
which meant that it lacks error rate
balance
but the the company says that well the
probability of recidivism was high for
individuals who scored high no matter
their race
so it does have predictive parity
which one do we care about
and then also like in in group fairness
we really talk a lot about um race and
gender like these are the groups that we
have and none of these concepts are like
very binary or very clear-cut measures
anyway
so um if you have a system you really
need to think about what are the aspects
of fairness that you care about what
does that apply to you what what kind of
parities do you want to check for
uh what are the groups and communities
that are affected
uh what are your legal risks risks and
exposure um you might audit a system and
you might see some slight disparity but
then the question is do you want to care
about it or not it's important to
document that it's important to check
that but sometimes if you might be like
no i'm like i'm fine
um whether but
at least you make that very explicit
um and then also there's a difference
between the world that we have and the
data that we have and the world that you
want to live in um for example if i'm in
the case of hiring
do i care about hiring with the same
rate that people are graduating from
computer science
and for example if i'm looking at gender
or do i want to have a company that has
a better gender balance than people who
are graduating and then how do i deal
with that which one is fair which one do
i care about
and obviously care about intended and
unintended and direct and indirect
consequences of productionizing your
system
this talk is
kind of
from a few different talks on papers
i've left the resources there
and now i welcome your questions
thanks adrian now we have
four minutes for questions i come with a
mic
how do issues of fairness interact with
issues of data protection for example we
can only gather data
from individuals
with respect to a given business purpose
and often we want we are told to work
with anonymized data sets where key
variables such as gender and race might
be missing while their strong correlates
remain unaccounted for so if i do if i
am for example doing a medical
predictive system which is
one of the domains i work with i may not
have
race as a variable so i cannot even
check
if the system that we're building
might discriminate
needlessly against one race versus
another what is best practice yes so
that's it that's a great question um it
touches on a few things uh first is that
um it's that's like a lot also relevant
like when we talk about gdpr in europe
uh we cannot collect that data there is
the complementary regulation coming out
of europe um for responsible ai and
transparent ai where it does tackle
those issues so if you want to check for
fairness explicitly then you you would
be allowed to have that data that's one
part another part is some companies do
choose to collect that data or use that
data regardless of the regulation and
pay the fine and i know some companies
do that because they want to do the
right thing another one is on the um
on the technical side there are also
models that you try you train on
partially known data so some people opt
in to share with you uh some of their
demographics and you try to build it
kind of a fair model based on whatever
definition you choose and then you can
show that that model is kind of fair for
others even though i don't know their
demographics so it like touches on a few
things
um i think for the presentations uh
quite uh interesting um
my question is usually about um when
dealing with models uh
the discrepancy that we have about the
data that we would like to have and the
one that we have
in the fact that we still need a certain
level of discrimination discriminative
power to run a business and that word in
itself i think makes clear like what
many models do right sometimes it's a
classification problem you're trying to
separate different groups and where do i
draw the lines say i'm in a bank and i
have to with a very amount of data i
have to decide whether a person should
receive a product and say one diffuse
the information that we have might be
age
and as a group uh i can say that usually
younger people tend to be riskier how do
what do i draw the line of being being
unfairly
assessing the risk of those customers
and being able to run a business and i
can use age and maybe some people say
that's okay
but but then if obviously if i use race
that that would be a step too far but i
said this is a step too far but it's age
okay to begin with and then
this sometimes it's never an engine
conversation so there may be no no
specific standards on commercial days so
it's um this one um
it's also a great question
it's
i always say it shouldn't be the job of
the data scientist who's developing to
make that decision what's important is
uh for me to be like if i'm the data
scientist for me to be able to to draw a
paradigm line and be like hey like based
on this metric i can have this
performance for this much fairness
and then the business makes a decision
and they make a decision based on the
risk
and profit factors
i'm not the one who needs to make that
decision i give them the option
when it comes to like choosing or not
choosing um certain attributes it's the
same thing um it's it's a lot of this is
about making all of these assumptions
explicit
and being very clear that we are using
this information for this reason
and then again the business can decide
whether they want to go public with this
information or just be private um but at
least they have it it's they're not
going to be surprised if an auditor
comes and and starts regarding their
systems
so let's thanks adrian again
a great talk